hey man i got a question from mr dirt
himself yeah uh
what's up with the joe dirk three dude
those theo vaughn in the picture
bring back brandy
randy brown
randy
kid rock come home everyone has the same
reaction to brandon
sparklers this question is still gone
snakes and sparklers
why do dogs jd three
brandy was so hot brandy was such a
stunner man oh my god she still is i see
her hair and there she's
unreal uh she was half the reason that
movie's so good is perfect casting yeah
she was great uh kid rock was great and
yeah um he's great he's got a new song
out too he's got a new album out he's
got a dope new song out though i know
he's so ridiculous i go
i go you're such a nice guy why do you
constantly make people get mad at you
you just you you step in your own [ __ ]
all the time because i love it so we did
joder too and joder and covington and
covington louisiana that's right boy
did you know we were there doing
anything are you here
here's the crazy and this is the this is
a good thing and why it's such a secret
beautiful little place never heard of
never
oh my god never heard a word by the way
just in a related story did you ever
have a rat tail
oh yeah where it's just a little pin
going straight down the back it's just a
little thin one like a sparkler down and
we used to put that little like kind of
uh
they'd put a little ribbon in it oh if
you were dating a girl a lot of times
she tied a ribbon on the end oh like
you're taking yeah sick this rat's mine
huh just roll up to sonic yeah the only
cheese he's eating is over here
like so
oh it's pretty gouda it's pretty good uh
jodor three i would rather do jodor
animated cartoon if you talked to
somebody about that recently because
then you can just be crazy because my
voice is about the same but i don't want
to be
too old strapping the wig on and being
like what's crapping yeah you know but i
love i love the movie i love
first of all i freely admit it wasn't a
huge hit um there was bigger hits out
there i did but just to have one stay in
the
world for all this time and
number one thing i get asked about so to
have something sort of stick around and
where i was like a decent person usually
i'm real sarcastic but it's like a good
guy a lot of people related to it yeah a
lot of people get picked on
it was very pro
the south because the south can sniff
out when you're making fun of them yeah
and i wasn't i was saying this is cool
and everything down there is cool and
there's a couple bad guys but this guy's
a good guy just trying to get through
[ __ ] life so people sort of took it
as like
that's inspirational way which is for
saying a movie that's kind of a goofy
movie but it did have that was oh yeah
through line so that's why i think it
hit with people and uh i don't want to
mess that up but it is fun to do joe
dirt stuff snakes and sparklers come up
every fourth of july and
i sell some dodge [ __ ] on my website you
know it's fun because you got to keep it
alive it's fun
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one